.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Vielleicht rettet Ihnen einer
dieser jungen Menschen mal das Leben.
Sie sind
angehende Pflegefachkräfte ...
... oder Rettungssanitäterinnen.
Die Ausbildung ist streng, der Beruf
spannend, aber anspruchsvoll.
Rebecca, Fanny ...
... Hélène und Lucas
wollen in einer Branche arbeiten,
die viele andere verlassen.
Warum - das erzählt diese Serie.
Im Spitalzentrum von Payerne
kam ein spezieller Notruf rein.
Fanny und ihr Teamkollege Damien
müssen sich beeilen.
* Sirene *
Es rief uns jemand an,
weil ein siebenjähriges Kind
vermutlich einen Schlaganfall hat.
Das ist lebensgefährlich.
Wo geht es durch?
- Nach der Kreuzung geradeaus.
Geradeaus?
- Ja, und dann rechts.
58, 60 - da ist es.
- 60.
* Spannende Musik *
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Wo tut es weh, Clara?
- Da.
Da. Und da auch.
- Ist gut. Clara, öffne den Mund.
Hast du ein Bonbon
oder einen Kaugummi im Mund?
Schau hierher, Clara.
Schau, so geht es einfacher.
* Weinen *
Versuche,
durch den Mund zu atmen. Okay?
Clara war in der Schule
und kriegte in der Turnstunde
plötzlich starke Bauchschmerzen.
Passiert das zum ersten Mal?
Sonst ist sie gesund?
Nimmt Sie Medikamente?
Keine Allergien?- Keine.
Clara, ich leuchte dir in die Augen.
Wir machen ein paar Dinge
gleichzeitig.- Du machst das super.
Die Pupillen sind sehr gross.
Die Symptome verunsichern
die beiden Rettungssanitäter.
Sie hatte eine Mydriasis.
D.h.,
dass beide Augen sehr gross waren.
Und zwar beidseitig,
das ist essenziell.
Bei einem Schlaganfall
ist häufig nur eine Pupille grösser
und die andere
entweder ganz klein oder normal.
Das und anderes bewog uns dazu,
einen Schlaganfall auszuschliessen.
Hattest du schon Bauchschmerzen?
- Aber etwas stimmte gar nicht.
Clara, was ist das?
Ähm ...
Ein Computer?
Ein Computer? Okay.
- Ich lege das hierhin.
Ich messe noch den Blutzucker
und die Temperatur.- Und das?
Ein Telefon?
- Ein Telefon, gut.
(Mutter)
Ich kann etwas anderes bringen.
Das?
- Ähm ...
Eine Birne?
- Eine Birne?
Das ist eine Mandarine.
Das ist das Telefon deiner Mutter.
Und das ist
die Fernbedienung für den Fernseher.
Die kennst du, oder?
Siehst du auch fern?
Ich messe jetzt Fieber
in deinem Ohr.
37,6 °C.
Sie hat leichtes Fieber
und ist ziemlich verwirrt.
Eine Diagnose zu stellen
ist im Moment schwierig.
Sie ist in allem
langsamer als sonst.
Ja. Sie ist bleich,
kann nicht klar sprechen ...
Jetzt sticht es kurz.
Claras Mutter
ist auch Pflegefachfrau.
Sie schafft es, Ruhe zu bewahren.
Ihre Mutter blieb sehr ruhig.
So zu arbeiten ist angenehm.
Sie reagierte entspannt,
verstand alles
und konnte genaue Antworten geben.
Wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Wie viele Finger sind das?
- Sagst du es deiner Mama?
Wie viele Finger zeige ich?
Clara?
- Drei.- Drei?
Blas mal deine Backen auf.
Ganz fest. Gut, gut, gut.
Oh ja, Donnerblitz,
du hast ja Kraft.
Berühr mal noch deine Nase.
Gut. Und mit dem anderen Finger?
Oh, das ist im Weg.
Jetzt mit dem anderen Finger.
- Versuch es. Es passiert nichts.
Mhm, gut.
- Ah, okay.
Clara muss ins Spital.
Streck die Arme weit nach vorne.
Gerade als sie gehen wollen,
tritt ein neues Symptom auf.
Tut es mehr weh,
wenn ich hier hinten draufdrücke?
Ist der Kopf schwer? Ja? Aha.
Ich hebe dich jetzt hoch
und trage dich bis zur Tragbahre.
Eins, zwei, drei.
- Wie eine kleine Prinzessin.
Sie hat Kopfschmerzen
und das Licht schmerzt.
Das könnte auf Meningitis hindeuten.
- Meningitis.
Das Genick tat ihr weh.
Dazu hatte sie etwas Fieber.
Sie hatte 37,4 °C.
Darum hätte es sein können,
dass sie eine Meningitis hat.
Bei einer Meningitis
ist die Hirnhaut entzündet.
Das ist natürlich lebensgefährlich.
Irgendetwas
gefiel uns ganz und gar nicht.
Aber wir konnten nicht genau sagen,
was los war.
Du kannst schneller.
- Ja.
Wir gehen zusammen ins Krankenauto.
Die Situation wird schlimmer
und man muss schnell machen.
Clara,
wir fahren gleich sehr schnell.
Darum hörst du dann auch die Sirene.
Du musst aber keine Angst haben.
Ich bin hier und deine Mama auch.
* Sirene *
Es kommt alles gut.
- Hier ist Damien von Nova 75.
Wir sind in 10 Min. bei dir
mit einer siebenjährigen Patientin.
Bist du umgefallen
und hast den Kopf angeschlagen?
(Fröhlich) Ja.
- Ja?
Könnten Sie
bei der Lehrerin nachfragen?
Es wäre gut zu wissen,
ob sie den Kopf angeschlagen hat.
Hast du den Kopf angeschlagen?
Die Lehrerin bestätigt,
dass sie im Turnen hingefallen sei.
Aber sie glaube, Clara
habe den Kopf nicht angeschlagen.
Und schon sind wir im Spital.
Es kommt alles gut.
So, Clara.
- Schau gut geradeaus.
Sehr gut.
Du bist ein mutiges Mädchen.
So.
Ich mache dich los
und wir legen dich aufs Bett.
Dann bist du nahe bei Mama.
Damien und Fanny übergeben
die Patientin dem Spitalteam.
Alle Informationen sind wichtig.
Man darf nichts vergessen.
Sie ist normalerweise gesund,
hat keine Allergien
und nimmt keine Medikamente.
Das Letzte, was sie gegessen hat,
war ein Znüni.
Wir wissen nicht, was es war.
Clara ist jetzt in guten Händen
und sie müssen wieder weiter.
Ich verabschiede mich, Clara.
Bedankst du dich?
- Danke vielmals.
Gerne geschehen, Clara.
Du bist so lieb.
Auf Wiedersehen. Alles Gute.
(Pflegerin) Super,
wie heisst deine Schule denn?
Hallo, Clara. Ich bin Emma,
die Assistenzkinderärztin.
Clara,
hast du den geschenkt gekriegt?
Ein Teddy.
Erzählst du mir,
was du heute gemacht hast?
Hast du ein Durcheinander im Kopf?
- Ja.
Kannst du dich
nicht mehr genau erinnern?
Das macht Angst, nicht wahr?
- Ja.
Aber keine Angst,
das wird schon wieder gut.
Super.
- Ui. Du hast vier Augen.
Habe ich vier Augen?
- Ja. Schau, Mami.
Okay, wo siehst du sie?
Hier.
Da, da, da, da ...
Okay.
Clara hat Halluzinationen.
Beunruhigende Symptome
für die Kinderärztin.
Kannst du das?
Zuerst mit dem einen Finger,
dann mit dem anderen.
Auf die Nase.
- Wo ist die Nase?
Berührst du sie?
- Und mit dem anderen Finger.
Wir müssen sie
einen Moment beobachten,
um zu klären, was passiert ist,
warum sie hingefallen ist.
Es ist gerade noch nicht klar.
Die Ärztin, die Eltern
und die Pflegenden sind ratlos.
In diesem Moment wird Claras
beste Freundin Emma-Joy eingeliefert.
Ist gut so.
So etwas.
- Schön.
Beste Freundinnen im Spital.
(Mutter) Was hat sie?
- Genau dasselbe.
Kann sie auch nicht
richtig sprechen und denken?
Sie sieht doppelt
und Leute, die nicht da sind.
Sie kann nicht richtig sprechen ...
Dass beide Mädchen
dieselben Symptome haben,
ist ein wichtiger Hinweis
für die Kinderärztin.
Entschuldigung,
können Sie mir sagen,
an welche Medikamente
sie zu Hause rankommen könnte?
Abgesehen von Dafalgan, Algifor etc.
An welche sie rankommen könnte ...
Sie hat heute Morgen
nichts genommen, ich war ja da.
Ähm ... Alle gängigen Medikamente,
die man halt so hat.
Plötzlich gibt es eine Spur.
- Das habe ich schon gesehen.
Ja?
- So ist es.
(Mutter)
Hast du ein Bonbon gegessen?
Oder eine Tablette?
* Unverständliches Flüstern *
Seid ehrlich und erfindet nichts.
Das ist wichtig.
Wir müssen es wissen.
- Das ist wichtig.
(Vater) Sag es lauter, Emma-Joy.
- (Mutter) Sag es laut.
(Pflegerin) Wir schimpfen nicht,
aber wir müssen es wissen,
um zu helfen.
- Ja, doch.
Ja,
wir haben eine Tablette gegessen.
Was habt ihr genommen?
Wie hat es ausgesehen?
Wo war die Tablette?
- In der Tasche.
In einer Tasche? Bei wem? Bei dir?
(Pflegerin) Clara, die Tablette,
war sie gross oder klein?
Etwa so klein.
- So klein?
(Mutter) War sie hart oder weich?
- Sie war weich.
Komisch.
- (Frau) War es wie ein Bonbon?
Hä?
- War es so lecker wie ein Bonbon?
Ja.
Claras Vater untersuchte zu Hause
die Tasche seiner Tochter.
Jetzt wird alles klar.
Okay, ich sage es der Ärztin.
Ist gut.
(Pflegerin) Was war es?
- Temesta Expidet.
Aus der abgeschlossenen Schublade.
Die Schachtel ist leer.
- Jesses.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
ob sie voll war.
Temesta ist
ein starkes Beruhigungsmedikament.
Beide haben je
drei bis vier genommen.
(Fanny) Auf Tablettenvergiftung
durch Temesta wäre ich nie gekommen.
Das kam mir gar nicht in den Sinn.
(Clara) Tablettenvergiftung?
- Claras Mutter ist erleichtert
und hat gleichzeitig
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Jetzt hat Clara sie doch genommen
und deiner Tochter gegeben.
Nein, hör auf.
Mach dir keine Sorgen.
- Doch. Ihr Vater ist ziemlich ...
Nein, komm. Es ist gut.
- Das kann nicht gut sein.
Das hätte uns auch passieren können.
- Das beschäftigt mich.
Sie haben die Tabletten gefunden
und sie rausgenommen,
obwohl wir sie wegsperrt hatten.
Sie lernen viel und schnell.
Clara, wenn Mama Tabletten
in einer Schublade versorgt,
und sie auch noch abschliesst,
heisst das "Finger weg".
Das wird nicht rausgenommen.
- Mami?- Das ist verboten.
Mhm.
- Mhm, ist gut?
Wir versorgen sie jetzt woanders,
aber du rührst sie nie mehr an.
Okay?
Die beiden Freundinnen
blieben noch ein paar Stunden
zur Beobachtung im Spital.
Dann durften sie nach Hause.
- Es wird nicht mehr schlimmer.
Die Eltern werden die Medikamente
bestimmt noch sicherer
verstecken und verschliessen.
Endlich ist es so weit
für Hélène und ihre beiden
Studienfreundinnen Célia und Emilie:
Sie fliegen für einen humanitären
Hilfseinsatz nach Afrika.
Schon ganz am Anfang ihres Studiums
beschlossen die drei,
zusammen nach Tansania zu gehen.
Danach wollen sie in einem Spital
in der Schweiz festangestellt werden.
Auf staubigen Pisten fahren sie
durch die Region des Kilimandscharo
zum Volk der Massai.
Hélène, Célia und Emilie lernen auf
dem Weg noch ein paar Worte Swahili.
* Sie sprechen dem Fahrer nach. *
Again.
Die Pflegefachfrauen aus der Schweiz
sind nervös.
Sie müssen heute einen Vortrag
vor Jugendlichen halten.
Es geht um die Beschneidung
der Frauen - ein heikles Thema.
Beschneidungen sind in Tansania
eigentlich verboten.
Trotzdem praktizieren die Massai
sie immer noch.
Wegen der Tradition.
Das ist einfach Teil der Tradition.
Sie wissen von dem Verbot,
und von dem grossen Risiko.
Es ist eine grosse Herausforderung.
Aber Hélène weiss:
Es ist ein dringendes Thema,
weil die Beschneidung
Frauen verstümmelt.
Aber über das Thema zu sprechen
ist schwierig.
Darum zählt das Hilfswerk darauf,
dass die jungen Pflegefachfrauen
aus dem Ausland
die Jugendlichen abholen
und sensibilisieren können.
Es sind viele gekommen.
Der Raum ist viel zu klein.
Traditionsgemäss
wird am Anfang jedes Schultages
Tansanias Nationalhymne gesungen.
# Tanzania, Tanzania ...
* Sie singen die Hymne. *
Hélène fällt sofort etwas auf.
Unser Auftritt war eigentlich
für junge Frauen geplant.
Also, für Frauen und Mädchen.
Aber die Leute der Organisation,
für die wir arbeiten,
haben es geschafft,
dass ein paar Jungs da sind.
Eine Überraschung,
die die Ausgangslage verändert
und die drei Schweizerinnen
noch nervöser macht.
Wir haben sie etwas überfordert.
Wir müssen sie fragen,
wie sie sich fühlen.
Der Hilfswerkmitarbeiter beruhigt sie
und gibt ihnen letzte Ratschläge.
Gestaltet es
so interaktiv wie möglich.
Ich heisse Hélène und bin 22.
Wir drei sind alle
Pflegefachfrauen aus der Schweiz.
In unserem Land gibt es die
Tradition der Beschneidung nicht.
Wir sind aber nicht nur hier,
um euch etwas beizubringen,
sondern auch um zu verstehen
und uns
über unsere Kulturen auszutauschen.
In der Massaigesellschaft sagt man,
dass unbeschnittene Frauen
keine richtigen Frauen seien und
sie deshalb niemand heiraten wolle.
Wer nicht beschnitten ist,
ist keine richtige Frau
und darf nicht heiraten.
- Die drei Pflegefachfrauen merken,
dass die Sprachbarriere
das Ganze noch komplizierter macht.
Aber Hélène ist mutig.
Gut?
Das wird etwas komisch.
* Lachen *
Wisst ihr, was das ist? Okay.
Hier rechts sieht es aus wie beim
Mann und links wie bei der Frau.
Es ist komisch. Ich weiss.
Wir haben eine Klitoris und
einen Penis an die Tafel gezeichnet.
Direkt standen ein paar Jungs auf
und gingen raus.
Ich weiss nicht,
warum sie sich nicht wohlfühlten.
Vielleicht
haben die Zeichnungen sie irritiert
oder das Thema passte ihnen nicht.
So ist es halt. Sie gingen raus.
Wir staunten darüber, aber das
gehört vielleicht auch dazu.
Bei den Mädchen sieht man es nicht.
Das ist im Körper drin.
Dort drin macht man den Schnitt.
Ohne es zu bemerken,
hat Hélène eine Grenze überschritten.
Aber wenn es hilft,
die Botschaft zu überbringen,
hat es sich gelohnt.
Wir wollen euch sagen, dass das
sehr schlecht für den Körper ist.
Wir kennen diese Tabus
bei uns nicht.
Man kann über alles sprechen,
auch in so einem Umfeld.
Ja und nein. Im schulischen
Sexualunterricht in der Schweiz
fühlen sich auch nicht alle wohl.
Wenn sie dürften,
würden auch einige rausgehen.
Aber man muss halt
im Zimmer bleiben.- Stimmt.
Die Pflegefachfrauen
machen mit dem Unterricht weiter.
Langsam kommt ein Austausch in Gang.
Die Männer wollen,
dass die Frauen beschnitten sind,
weil sie denken, dass die Frauen
dann weniger Lust verspüren
und darum weniger fremdgehen.
Für die Männer
ist die Beschneidung gut.
Stimmt das?
Nach der Beschneidung ist es
sehr schmerzhaft für die Frau.
Darum hat sie auch weniger Lust.
Sie haben
wirklich gute Fragen gestellt.
Für ihr Alter, finde ich.
Mit 13 so erwachsen zu sein,
ist beeindruckend.
Das Eis ist gebrochen
und das Gespräch
geht auch nach dem Unterricht weiter.
Woher kommen Sie?
- (Alle drei) Aus der Schweiz.
Spricht man in der Schweiz Spanisch?
- Nein, Französisch.
Ihren ersten Auftrag haben
Hélène, Emilie und Célia hinter sich.
* Fröhliche afrikanische Musik *
* Dynamische, rockige Musik *
Sonntagmorgen.
Lucas
macht eine Motorradtour mit Freunden.
Motorradfahren
ist seine Leidenschaft.
Es hilft ihm dabei, abzuschalten.
Die Gruppe trifft sich regelmässig,
um eine Tour zu machen
und Neuigkeiten auszutauschen.
Vorbei und abgeschlossen?
- Ja, fertig mit Schule.
Lucas musste nach dem Diplom
noch ins Militär.
Jetzt könnte sein Berufsleben
so richtig losgehen.
Aber es ist nicht einfach,
eine Stelle zu finden.
Die Ausbildung ist fertig.
Jetzt möchte ich
eine Arbeitsstelle finden.
Aber viel gibt es nicht.
Es werden nicht viele gesucht.
Schon etwas enttäuschend.
- Sehr.
Man hat ihm
nur eine Temporärstelle angeboten,
um Covid-Impfungen und -Tests
zu machen.
Das klingt vielleicht eingebildet,
aber ich habe nicht
drei Jahre studiert,
um Covid-Impfungen und -Tests
zu machen.- Aber bis du was hast.
Lucas
und seine Freundinnen und Freunde
sind sich sehr nahe.
Solche Motorradausflüge helfen ihm,
seinen Frust zu verarbeiten.
Im Universitätsspital von Genf
beginnen manche Tage gut ...
Wo ist mein Fiebermesser?
Haben sie den geklaut?
Das gibt's doch nicht.
Man stiehlt nicht von Kollegen.
Tja, dann messe ich später Fieber.
... und an anderen Morgen
läuft es weniger rund.
(Mann) Läuft es nicht?
- Nein, es läuft nicht.
Tja, dann halt ohne Computer.
Trotzdem
darf man den Humor nicht verlieren.
Gabrielle wurde am Tag vorher
notfallmässig eingeliefert.
Sie hat Probleme mit der Gallenblase.
Ich werde später Fieber messen.
Man hat meinen Fiebermesser geklaut.
Das ist wenig Wasser.
- Möchten Sie gerne mehr?
Ein Tröpfchen noch.
Es ist zwar kein Champagner ...
- Nein. Trotzdem tut es gut.
Rebecca
darf nicht zu viel Wasser geben,
weil Gabrielles Gallenblase
untersucht werden muss.
Gerade ist gut, aber wenn etwas ist,
melde ich mich.- Gut.
Erste Arztvisite.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Schlecht.- Schlecht?
Sie haben eine Cholezystitis,
eine Gallenblasenentzündung.
Um das zu behandeln, braucht es
einen chirurgischen Eingriff.- Gut.
Und sobald sie entfernt ist,
was ist dann?
Habe ich dann keine Schmerzen mehr?
Ist es also sinnvoll,
sie rauszunehmen?
Ja, klar.
- Ah, ja.
Gabrielle hatte schon
einige gesundheitliche Probleme.
Man musste ihr
sogar schon Organe entfernen.
Die, die sich am dümmsten
verhielten, sind entfernt.
Dann entfernen wir die auch noch.
Lassen Sie mir
einfach den Magen und die Leber.
Gabrielle nimmt es zwar mit Humor,
aber sie ist trotzdem beunruhigt.
Okay, das ist gut.
Ich hänge noch sehr am Leben.
- Schön.
Ich möchte
meine Enkel aufwachsen sehen.
Jetzt ist es so weit:
Die Gallenblase
kann untersucht werden.
Gabrielle ist nüchtern und bereit.
Rebecca und der Arzt schauen, ob der
Untersuchungstermin bestätigt ist.
Ah, hier unten. Gastro.
Sie möchte so schnell wie möglich
untersucht und operiert werden,
weil sie grosse Schmerzen hat
und auch schnell nach Hause möchte.
Oh, Herr Doktor. Ich hoffe,
Sie haben gute Nachrichten.
Ich weiss nicht.
Also, ich habe mit
den Gastroenterologen gesprochen.
Sie können die Untersuchung
erst morgen machen.
Sie dürfen also heute
noch was essen, wenn Sie können.
Puh, das kann ich nicht garantieren.
Schon gut.
- Vielleicht etwas Glacé oder so.
Ich schaue mal, ob wir was haben.
Gabrielle lacht zwar immer noch,
aber es ist hart für sie.
Das weiss Rebecca.
Was soll ich Ihnen bringen?
Wollen Sie was Kleines essen?
- Ein Joghurt gerne.
In einem so schwierigen Moment
tut jede kleine Zuwendung gut.
Sie sind ein Schatz.
- Ein Ananasjoghurt.
Das ist gut. Danke.
Im Spital
erhält man eine Lektion fürs Leben.
Es verändert das Leben.
Das passiert im Spital.
Man lernt ...
... zwischen wichtigen und
belanglosen Dingen zu unterscheiden.
Die Tage gehen vorbei
und die Probleme bleiben.
Diesmal ist die Batterie leer,
obwohl ich sie angeschlossen habe.
Ich denke, es sollte gehen.
Sonst halt mit Papier und Bleistift.
Es geht nicht. Das nervt.
Gabrielle hat immer noch
keinen Untersuchungstermin.
Darum hat sie
auch schlecht geschlafen.
Es hiess, heute Morgen.
Und ich dachte: "Oi-oi-oi."
Langsam
strapaziert das meine Geduld.
Ich war in der Nacht
ziemlich durcheinander.
Wenn sie keine Zeit haben ...
Gabrielle ist ziemlich angespannt
und stritt sich schon frühmorgens
mit der Hilfspflegerin.
Ich will Sie nicht mehr sehen.
So lernt man,
wie man mit den Leuten umgeht.
Haben Sie vergessen,
was sie gestern geboten hat?
Ich mische mich nicht ein.
Ich höre zu, was die Patientin sagt.
Aber ich sage nie,
"Wie recht Sie haben" oder so.
Nie. Es geht um Kolleginnen,
und wir sind ein Team.
Aber wenn mir etwas nicht passt,
bespreche ich das mit ihr
unter vier Augen.
Während Gabrielle
auf ihre Untersuchung wartet,
kümmert Rebecca sich darum,
dass die Patientin
genug Schmerzmittel erhält.
Mittlerweile
gelingt es ihr problemlos,
einen Venenkatheter zu legen.
Tut es weh, wenn ich steche?
- Ich habe nichts gespürt.
Sehr gut.
- Sie sind ein Engel.
Sie machen das so gut.
Chapeau, bei diesen kleinen Venen.
Das kann nicht jeder.
Ich gebe Ihnen meine Hand.
- Ah, so schön.
Ich mache Ihnen einen Heiratsantrag.
Wenigstens jemand.
- Ich bitte darum.
Ah ja? Nein. Was?
Eine Botschaft an meinen Partner,
wissen Sie.
Meine Kinder sind alle verheiratet
und selbst schon Eltern.
Ich bin vergeben, aber er
muss sich endlich entscheiden.
Bis nachher.
- Bis später.
Am dritten Tag klappt es endlich.
Gabrielles Gallenblase
wird untersucht.
Ich habe es dorthin gelegt.
Ah ja.
Warten Sie, ich lege es
auf das andere Tablar.
Haben Sie allen Schmuck abgenommen?
- Ja.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Bis später.
Ab jetzt kümmert sich das Team
der Gastroenterologie um Gabrielle.
Haben Sie
die Ergebnisse der Radiologie?
Nach dem langen Warten ist sie
angespannt und hat keine Nerven mehr.
Tut mir leid,
die Gefühle kommen einfach hoch.
Gar kein Problem.
Sie dürfen loslassen.
Tief durchatmen und entspannen.
Schieben Sie das weg und
lassen Sie es nicht an sich heran.
Ist gut?
- Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Gabrielle schläft für 45 Min.
Die Mediziner
untersuchen ihre Gallenblase
mit einer endoskopischen Kamera
und es gelingt ihnen,
die Gallenwege teilweise freizulegen,
damit die Schmerzen zurückgehen.
- Frau Isabella. Hören Sie uns?
Die Untersuchung ist vorbei.
Können Sie den Mund öffnen?
Die Untersuchung verlief gut.
Zurück auf der Abteilung
wird sie wieder von Rebecca betreut.
Ich kann die Augen
nicht offenhalten.
Das ist normal nach einer Narkose.
Ruhen Sie sich aus.
Es braucht einen weiteren Eingriff,
damit Gabrielle wieder gesund wird:
Man muss die Gallenblase entfernen.
* Swahili *
Again.
* Sie sprechen dem Fahrer nach. *
Seit einer Woche sind Hélène,
Emilie und Célia jetzt in Tansania.
Heute sind sie unterwegs
zu einer Krankenstation.
Es ist schon ein Kulturschock.
So vieles ist anders
als bei uns in der Schweiz.
Aber ich habe das
nicht anders erwartet.
Wer hierherreist, weiss das.
Vom Alltag her
ist es komplett anders.
Es gibt jeden Tag etwas, über das
man staunt und das ungewöhnlich ist.
Die drei Pflegefachfrauen werden
noch mehr Überraschungen erleben.
Heute treffen sie Elisha.
Sie ist nicht nur Pflegerin,
sondern kümmert sich
auch um die Familienplanung.
* Sie sprechen Swahili. *
Hier spricht man Swahili.
Nur wenige verstehen Englisch.
Hélène versteht kein Wort.
* Sie sprechen Swahili. *
Die Frau hat schon zwei Kinder
und möchte im Moment kein drittes.
Aber vielleicht in ein paar Jahren.
Elisha empfiehlt darum
ein Hormonimplantat,
das sie für drei Jahre schützt.
Wir kontrollieren alle Werte
und ihr Gewicht.
Dann führen wir
das Hormonstäbchen ein.- Okay.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen
mit der Pflegerin/Hebamme
zusammengearbeitet,
aber die Sprachbarriere
ist schon mühsam.
Es macht es nicht einfach,
generell im Alltag.
Auch das eingesetzte Material
ist ungewohnt für Hélène.
Ich muss fragen,
wie das funktioniert.
Zum Glück ist Elisha nicht weit weg.
Nachdem alles gemessen wurde,
ist die Frau bereit
für das Hormonstäbchen.
Die Frauen können nicht
einfach Verhütungsmittel brauchen.
Die Männer gestatten das nicht.
Nur wer Kinder zeugt,
gilt als richtiger Mann.
Also wollen sie Kinder.
Die Frau kann nicht frei
entscheiden, ob sie verhüten will
und auch nicht, mit welchen Mitteln.
Wenn sie verhüten will,
muss sie es so machen,
dass man es nicht sieht oder merkt.
Und man kann sich auch gar nicht
richtig erkundigen, was es gibt.
Sie kennen die Möglichkeiten nicht
und sind
nicht so informiert wie wir.
Das Gerät funktioniert nicht richtig
und das Hormonstäbchen
lässt sich nicht implantieren.
Die Pflegerin
muss noch mal von vorne beginnen.
Ich hoffe,
dieses Mal funktioniert es.
Den Verband, bitte.
Beim zweiten Versuch gelingt es.
Einen Computer gibt es hier nicht.
Alles wird von Hand aufgeschrieben.
Das hält nun drei Jahre.
Dann nehmen wir es raus.
Kommen noch weitere Patientinnen?
Wir hatten einen schwierigen Fall.
Der Mann hatte herausgefunden,
dass seine Frau
ein Hormonimplantat hat.
Wissen Sie, was er gemacht hat?
Er hat sein Messer genommen,
hier aufgeschnitten
und das Implantat rausgenommen.
Dann brachte er uns die Frau zurück
und sagte:
"Ich habe es herausgenommen.
Kümmern Sie sich um die Patientin."
Das war wirklich tragisch.
Darum haben die Frauen auch Angst.
Es gibt aber trotzdem Frauen,
die hierherkommen.
Wie die neue Patientin,
die auch schon zwei Kinder hat
und nicht noch mehr möchte.
Sie möchte verhüten.
Aber ihr Mann
will nichts davon wissen.
Ich habe ihr geraten,
sich sterilisieren zu lassen.
Die junge Frau
will darüber nachdenken.
Elisha schlägt ihr vor, erst mal mit
einer Dreimonatsspritze zu verhüten.
Hélène traut sich das zu
und übernimmt.
Sie spricht
sogar ein paar Worte Swahili.
(Swahili) Ich heisse Hélène.
Die Stimmung ist entspannt
und dieses Mal
gelingt Hélène jeder Handgriff.
Ist das wie eine Impfung?
- Ja.
Intramuskulär.
Setzten Sie die Spitze
im 90-Grad-Winkel an.
Ist es gut so?
Das Erlebnis hier hat für mich
ein paar Dinge relativiert.
Aspekte wie Kultur,
oder was wir unter Pflege
in der Schweiz verstehen.
Hier ist vieles gar nicht möglich.
Gerade, was Pflege angeht, hat man
hier einen ganz anderen Standard,
weil das Geld
oder das Material fehlt.
Aber vieles läuft hier auch gut.
Darum fragt man sich schon,
ob wir all das,
was wir in der Schweiz haben,
auch wirklich brauchen
und ob der Luxus nötig ist.
Es ginge auch mit weniger.
Klar verringert das
auch die Überlebenschancen,
aber ich sehe vieles
in einem neuen Kontext.
Diese Erfahrungen
werden Hélène, Emilie und Célia
in ihren Berufsalltag mitnehmen.
Und sie werden sie wohl
ein Leben lang begleiten.
* Sie singen ein Lied. *
Im Geriatriespital
Trois-Chêne in Genf.
Seit einem Monat arbeitet Lucas
hier auf der Covid-Station,
der Abteilung 21.
Er kommt heute doch nicht.
- Nicht? Warum?
Er geht zurück in die 41.
Er ist nicht positiv.
Keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Aber der Patient in der 17
hat kein Long Covid, oder?
Das wurde im Patientendossier
nicht geändert.
Darum gilt er bei uns
immer noch als positiv.
Das ist das Problem.
Abteilung 21, Lucas, grüezi.
Lucas gehört zum Team
der sog. Blauwesten.
Bei ihnen läuft vieles zusammen,
was im Spital passiert.
Sie helfen so,
die Pflege zu entlasten.
Er ist in der 217.
Im letzten Zimmer.
Ich musste das nehmen, was es hatte.
Einfach im Zimmer,
um ihn vorzubereiten.
Damit er nachher gehen kann. Gerne.
Man kommt in ein Berufsfeld rein,
in dem es kriselt.
Im Studium war das nicht
gross Thema. Aber das ist gut so.
Es ist schwierig, sich unter
diesen Umständen zu konzentrieren.
Das habe ich gemacht, das auch ...
Ah ja.
Lucas arbeitet 100 %
und hat unregelmässige Arbeitszeiten.
Kommt er zurück?
Mittlerweile
fühle ich mich wohl bei der Arbeit.
Nicht ganz wie ein Fisch im Wasser,
aber ich fühle mich doch schon wohl.
Grüezi.
Es geht mir gut.
Nein, nein, nein.
Manchmal
braucht es auch sehr viel Geduld.
Beobachten Sie mich etwa?
- Nein, nein.
Ich laufe wohl eher Ihnen hinterher.
Die Kleider können Sie
zu Hause wieder anziehen, okay?
Gut.
Die Geduld
steht stark auf dem Prüfstand.
Gerade bei Leuten,
die etwas verwirrt sind,
oder die Mühe
mit ihrer Identität haben
oder damit,
wo sie sind und was passiert.
Wir öffnen den Vorhang,
damit etwas Sonne reinkommt.
Nützen wir das aus.
Guten Appetit, Frau Pilotti.
- Das sieht doch nicht aus.
Das ist halb so wild.
Sie sind entschuldigt.
- Ach ja.
Die Patientinnen und Patienten
in Lucas' Abteilung bleiben lange.
Manchmal ein paar Wochen.
Es gibt immer noch dieses Klischee,
dass die Leute in die Geriatrie
gingen, um zu sterben.
Oder dass die Patienten nur dorthin
gehen, wenn sie am Ende sind.
Aber die Geriatrie
ist eher eine Pflegephilosophie.
Denn es geht um ältere
und zerbrechliche Menschen.
Sie haben meistens
speziellere Bedürfnisse.
Grüezi.
Grüezi, Herr Thomas.
- Lucas.
Schreiben Sie es bitte an die Tafel.
- Gerne.
Das bleibt mir sonst nicht.
- Ich bin heute Ihr Pflegefachmann.
Das ist bestens, Herr Lucas.
- Wie geht es Ihnen?
Sehr gut?
- Das freut mich.
Aber zu Hause wäre es besser.
- Das glaube ich.
Darum tun wir alles,
damit Sie so schnell wie möglich
nach Hause können.
Achtung, das sind Muskeln.
Aufpassen. Das ist nicht nichts.
Meine Muskeln.
- Ich bin ganz ruhig.
Sie haben allen Grund dazu.
Ich fasse Ihre Freundin
sicher nicht an.
Damit das klar ist.
- Ja.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
dass nur ein Teil der Patienten
nachher ins Pflegeheim geht.
Die meisten können nach ihrem
Aufenthalt im Spital nach Hause.
Maurice
kam nach einem Spitalaufenthalt
für zehn Tage auf die Abteilung 21.
Ich bin auf einer Spitaltour.
Zuerst war ich
in Meyrin im Spital La Tour.
Dann kam ich in die Nähe von Nyon.
Ich besuche die Spitäler
der Kantone Genf und Waadt.
Ich mache Notizen, um rauszufinden,
welches das Beste ist.
Gut.
Was ist passiert?
Was ist mir passiert?
Es ging vier Monate.
Ich stand jeden Tag morgens auf
und es ging mir immer schlechter.
Ich kam gerade noch knapp
von der Küche zur Toilette
und dann noch ins Zimmer.
Dann war fertig.
Ich konnte nicht mehr gehen.
Ich konnte nichts mehr.
Meine Kraft war einfach am Ende.
Appetitlosigkeit, Gewichtsverlust -
deutet auf Covid hin.
Er hat auch zu wenig Blut.
Aber er war nicht lange hier und ist
wieder fit. Er ist über den Berg.
Maurice
hat das Schlimmste hinter sich.
Er hat Covid überstanden.
Jetzt kommt die Arztvisite.
- Geht es Ihnen gut?
Sehr gut.
- Wissen Sie, was morgen ist?
Nein, aber mit so hübschen
Pflegefachfrauen wie Ihnen ...
Wir gehören zum Ärzteteam.
- Ah, eine Ärztin?
Ich bin so krank.
Das ändert nicht viel.
- Ich nehme es nicht persönlich.
Unser Pflegefachmann ist stark.
- Ja.
Wenn man mit ihm rumspaziert,
hat man Vertrauen.
Aha.
- Er hält einen gut.
Gerade so? Das ist doch gut.
- Aber ja ...
Wenn man einen Zarten
als Pfleger hat ...
Damit kann man nichts anfangen.
- Es gibt nicht viele solche.
Man muss manchmal das Kalb machen.
Sonst ist das Leben nicht so lustig.
Noch mal ein Covid-Test
vor dem Heimgehen.
* Angestrengte Geräusche *
Hör auf.
- Und fertig.
Tut mir leid. Danke für Ihre Geduld.
Das ist eine grässliche Tortur.
- Mhm. Ich weiss.
Maurice ist sich bewusst,
dass er Glück hatte
und im Spital gut betreut wurde.
Privilegiert.
Ich denke, das ist das Wort.
Das sollten sich ...* Schniefen *
Tut mir leid.
Das sollten sich viele merken.
Ja, wir sind privilegiert.
Ich bin ganz neu.
- Wie neu?
Ja, ganz neu.
Es ist das Spital, das so ...
Wie sagt man?
- Das Sie heilte?
Ja.
- Sicher, das ist das Ziel.
Ja, ich bin geheilt.
- Das ist perfekt.
Ich habe die Medikamente
für heute Morgen vorbereitet.
Maurice muss zuerst in die Reha,
bevor er nach Hause kann.
Aber ... Ah, ich will das nicht.
Das Leben ist so schön.
Aber in einem Leben
kann vieles passieren.
Es gibt Wasserfälle
und es gibt Bäche ...
Aber das Leben ist schön.
Lucas ist immer bereit,
um mitzuhelfen
und wurde in nur ein paar Monaten
ein geschätzter Kollege.
Er hofft, dass er eines Tages
auf der Notfallstation arbeiten kann.
Hélène geniesst
ihren Aufenthalt in Tansania.
Wenn sie zurückkommt, wird sie im
Universitätsspital Lausanne arbeiten.
Sie hat dort eine Stelle
in der Notfallstation ergattert.
Fanny ist immer noch
unermüdlich unterwegs.
Ihr Ziel ist es, bald in ihrem
Wohnkanton Fribourg zu arbeiten.
Rebecca möchte einen
humanitären Einsatz in Togo machen
und irgendwann Ausbildnerin
von Pflegefachleuten sein.
Sie arbeiten jetzt
schon ein Jahr auf ihrem Beruf
und alle vier machen ihn
immer noch mit Leidenschaft.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022